well when I first learned that I was
going to come to MIT I was actually very
happy because I had been here before I
was really a bit intimidated by the sort
of level of technology that people were
working on here but also very excited
about it so I had some experience with
MIT before I came here for the McDermott
award residency
one of the things I did when I was here
is I visited Fredo Durand and the
computational photography lab and that
was truly thrilling he's doing really
extraordinary things he's he's working
with cameras in such a way that he's
really helping to invent the new you
know the new generation of photography
and he's doing that by combining the
computational power of computers with
the optical power of lenses and cameras
to take in reality so artistically for
me it means that which has been one of
the hallmarks of artistic practice is
the artist making a decision on the spot
of what they're going to do you don't
have to do that anymore you can
literally have it all have the perfect
image in all aspects and then you can
work with that image you can manipulate
it and you can make it be any one of a
number of different stylistic choices
which you had to invest in before and
actually take the shot in that way you
were locked into just that way so if you
wanted to have 10 choices when you later
to get the one you wanted you how to
shoot 10 separate things so it's really
amazing he's brought at it he's brought
previously sort of fixed options into
the realm of personal choice and
personal preference
impressed when I visited here oh she
she's lab of tangible media there was
something so natural and affirming to me
when I engaged his some of the objects
that he and his students have created in
that laboratory which are based on the
tactile sense and I think he's onto
something really powerful because in
today's age people feel the average
person not certainly not the people who
work here and live with technology the
average person has a kind of a mistrust
of Technology if you can't see it if you
can't touch it they don't quite believe
it they don't quite trust it because of
the way we are constructed physiological
IAM hit oh she has kind of figured this
out that this is an essential thing and
when i was in the lab it was interesting
to see how little instruction i need to
engage the physical objects he has there
which I could touch with my hand and
manipulate with my hand
into the end of the optical age in the
sense that what I mean by that is during
the Renaissance there was an incredible
shift from medieval culture which dealt
with invisible realities which is why
they painted the sky golden medieval
pictures and not blue they saw the blue
sky like we did but they painted a gold
because the notion of God the divine
being as the origin of everything was
much more real and powerful to them than
the blue sky which was just some
physical thing what and so the spiritual
dimension was more real then we moved
into the Renaissance where that
completely shifted human isn't arrived
and all of a sudden human beings are at
the center of the world and our
inventions and creations and that goes
on primarily the main instrument was
optics that lasted six hundred years
until the present moment we are now not
only facing a major ecological crisis in
terms of global warming we're not only
facing right now a major economic crisis
with the the economic meltdown but we're
also at the end of an era where we're
what the eye sees isn't necessarily the
real thing that reality has submerged to
the level of a code to the level of some
inner information it's embedded in
things and it's malleable so
subjectivity is now going to become the
new objectivity and it's very very
confusing for people we're going to have
to negotiate through this period now of
change and we're going to have to come
out the other side and really the
essential part of it is what is real
I visited Todd Micawber in his lab he's
working on a couple of projects opera
the future is one of them and I've done
operas before and that was pretty
exciting to see him he's working on a
new opera now about a person who
actually dies and then is it is himself
a technological person and before he
dies he figures out a way to it to
encode his presence his consciousness
into artificial technology so he ends up
like in 2001 the Space Oddity he becomes
the room I think he's taught is really
working with relevant issues of today
this is a real issue today every time
you make a cell phone call you're
dealing with a disembodied presence so
it's a real real concurrent kind of
issues obviously I saw and was treated
very kindly and and with generosity by
the people who I met here in the various
labs and I think a lot of that for me
was exciting because I felt like I was
in the future certainly these kinds of
things will come become the future I
mean Todd Mac over for example told me
that the that game that's so popular now
with the kids my teenage boy included
guitar hero you know came out of
research originally done in his lab
ultimately in that and that is I'm not
talking here in any kind of economic
terms any kind of like you know issues
related to profits and you know your
livelihood I'm just talking about
strictly culturally and artistically
that that thing came out of this lab
came out of this way of thinking and
it's affected entire generation of
people